atteints d'insuffisance rénale franco di
vita reçoit des traitements de dialyse
trois fois par semaine même s'il avait
déjà reçu une première dose de vaccin
il a contracté la coved 19 en mars
dernier mais sûrement ses bijoux à
l'hôpital après les bijoux sortis je
t'ai fait backup est là aujourd'hui je
commence à me sentais beaucoup mieux et
je pense qu'on a besoin le deuxième
vaccin pour améliorer la situation de
survivre il a participé à une étude
menée par des néphrologues québécois
pour mesurer l'efficacité d'une première
dose du vaccin de pfizer bio ntech chez
les patients dialysés
selon les résultats préliminaires 29
patients sur 46 c'est à dire 63 pour ça
non développé aucun anticorps huit
semaines après l'avoir reçue en était
pas très très surprise parce que on sait
que les patients dialysés ont des
problèmes avec leur immunité
s'ils contractent l'aco vide il on
devait à 30 % de risque d'en mourir un
ton dix fois plus élevé que dans la
population en général donc quelques
semaines le deuxième dos depuis le 9
avril l'institut national de santé
publique du québec recommande que les
personnes fortement immunosupprimées et
dialysés obtiennent une deuxième dose de
vaccin quatre semaines après la première
le gouvernement a l'intention d'aller de
l'avant mais est incapable de dire qu'à
jettera de pouvoir donner une réponse le
match doit être capable de de maths en
place la fonction de l'opinion qui m'ont
été mise je suis je suis en attente de
cette opinion ne plus réagir
excessivement rapidement surtout qu'une
autre étude menée en israël montre que
l'immense majorité des patients dialysés
développent des anticorps
quand ils reçoivent deux doses de
vaccins dans un intervalle de trois
semaines maintenant qu'on a ces données
là oui là il faut procéder le plus
rapidement possible pour différentes
raisons d'abord pour protéger les
patients
présentement les patients
immunodéficients ou immunosupprimées
sont dans un flou assez général parce
que non seulement
la deuxième dose n'est pas encore fixé
mais on était passé voir fonctionner en
plus de raccourcir les délais entre les
deux doses plusieurs experts estiment
que les personnes qui ont un système
immunitaire affaibli pourrait avoir
besoin de doses supplémentaires pour
combattre la coved et ce levier bachand
radio canada montréal